speak up is to add a new recurring expense and split it among all household
members okay click the add exchange button right on the front page yeah
it'll be rent so just tap all the fields to fill them out okay there's no type
category doesn't matter whatever rent category I guess I'm just splitting with
everyone should amount 20 into the date so like repeat was there weekly weekly
and split with all flatmates right yeah okay so like your flatmates can I just
make sure that you're speaking up a little bit just make sure that the
hello hello and description I just have that through us and create exchange
created okay sweet that's pretty much it and are you confident with all that yep
yeah that's pretty easy easy as cool now second task is to ensure oh wait okay
yeah now pay an additional expense this will be power and yeah just paying
expense okay cool power so pay the person who paid for power I'm gonna
click pay yeah and I got a quick power yeah I believe okay pay for power yes
cool all right come again you come that's pretty simple sweet easy ass okay
and now third task is to just view your past expenses and look for garbage that
was sorted out last week okay I'll probably go to expenses to find that one
yeah and I'll probably go to garbage cool and just tell me the names of the
people who did it person one a person to easy cool cheers
cool and you're confident than that happened yeah that's pretty easy cool
yes now to check now what you need to do is check the insights and look at the
monthly breakdown for rent click insights I'm gonna see rent I'm assuming
it's clickable but yeah I'm not actually sure yep monthly breakdown thanks
monthly breakdown up here that's pretty simple sweet cool and you're pretty
confident with what's happening mm-hmm yep cool yeah and the fifth task is now
to test customization options for display okay I'm probably gonna go up
here yeah try find something like settings unless I'm missing a
customizability button household settings settings or user profile I'm
gonna go app settings cool display settings yeah okay so just play around
the display settings and then check your accessibility options as well dark mode
and let's see high contrast and color blank frame just for fun yeah those were
sweet as cool and you're confident that kind of does its thing yep cool now the
final task is to check help and support functionalities so fill out check out
the FAQ as well as submit a contact support form all right I'm in settings
as I was before I'm just gonna click frequently ask questions have a look at
one speaking up what is the purpose of the expense follow us yep can see it all
here ask questions put that away contact support just contact support and
enter a form pretty easy Cassie Cassie Cassie has no message oh yeah send yep
that'll work cool that's easy yep and you're confident all this stuff is done
yep easy ass cool that's pretty much it cool cool awesome sweet ass